i want to get back to the international
crisis in taiwan and the economy and the
migration crisis at the border but i'm
sorry i'm getting breaking news this is
really urgent important breaking news
the singer demi lovato
has gone back from using
they pronouns to using she
pronouns demi take it away
i've actually adopted the pronouns of
she her again
so for me
i'm such a fluid person that i don't
really
i don't find that i am
i felt like especially last year my
energy was balanced and my masculine and
feminine energy
so that when i was faced with the choice
of walking into a bathroom and it said
women and men i didn't feel like there
was a bathroom for me because i didn't
feel necessarily like a woman i didn't
feel like a man
um i just felt like a human
and that's what they them is is about
for me it's just about like
feeling human at your core
recently i've been feeling more feminine
so i've adopted her again
but i think what's important is like
nobody's perfect everyone messes up
pronouns at some point and especially
when people are learning it's just all
about respect
it is not a major news story when
hollywood celebrities say really stupid
things and believe really kooky bizarre
occult
new agey nonsense
it is sad when the entire culture goes
along with it that that is really sad we
expect this
of hollywood celebrities through through
whom one can blow in the left ear and
see one's breath come out the right ear
generally speaking we expect that
it's very sad when the entire culture
and the leaders of our most powerful
institutions all go along with that as
well how how sad is it
that we are living at a time
where
actress goes by she
is a news story that people are talking
about that's reported in a lot of
newspapers that's that's really really
sad
now what what demi lovato has just
demonstrated is going to happen to a lot
of people in the coming years this is
why the story i think really matters
when we're looking ahead five or ten
years
demi lovato
was swept up in this cultural craze of
transgenderism pretending that men and
women don't really exist as discrete
categories and for a while she she
changed the pronouns that she used she
changed the symbols that that that she
uses and other people use to refer to
her true self and then she realized that
was dumb and she switched back and she
admitted okay i made a mistake that was
dumb but okay call me a woman again i
know that i'm a woman again
demi lovato never chopped off her
breasts demi lovato never won underwent
some crazy surgery demi lovato never
went on
cross-sex hormones taking a lot of
testosterone or anything like that demi
lovato didn't stop her puberty and
permanently destroy her biochemistry and
give herself osteoporosis at age nine
like it's happening right now to lots of
kids
a lot of kids are being swept away in
the same stupid social craze called
transgenderism that demi lovato was
swept away with and demi lovato will
face zero consequences from it it was
just a funny little pr stunt for a few
months for the kids who are looking to
her and and more importantly looking to
people who have even more cultural and
political influence than her and looking
to the public health officials that are
that are pushing this on kids and
looking to the big pharma companies that
are peddling this to little kids
those kids are not going to get out so
easy those kids are going to have lots
of long-term health problems they're all
going to have intense psychological
scarring and their lives are in many
ways going to be deeply damaged if not
ruined because of this ideology so it's
funny it's cool that demi could try that
on for a little bit hahaha okay but now
i'm she again tihihi but
what about the people
who will have to pay the price hollywood
never has to pay the price for anything
real people do have to pay the price
what's going to happen
to them speaking of hollywood
really huge news for liz cheney you know
liz cheney you know that principled
republican that she's a principled true
conservative
unlike all the republican party
politicians and the last republican
president and all the all the actual
right-wingers who vote for republicans
and conservative policies
liz cheney
who is the face of the january 6th
committee liz cheney who on every
crucial matter squishes to the democrats
she just got a major endorsement from
kevin
costner that's right kevin costner took
a picture wearing a shirt saying i
support liz janey and liz posted this
with a line she says real men
put country over party
i'm not sure why this is a news story
kevin costner is a hollywood liberal i
like kevin costner's work very much he's
an excellent actor kevin costner is a
liberal
from hollywood who
supported pete booty judge in 2020 pete
vodajedge my least favorite candidate
hey guys hi there hi i'm the reasonable
one so kevin costner
supports dems and and endorses dams and
campaigns for them and now he's doing
the same thing he's just doing what he
always does he's supporting
democrats because liz cheney is a de
facto democrat she has an r next to her
name and she'll even vote with the
republicans on issues that don't really
matter where her vote is not significant
but on crucial matters where the vote
really does matter she sides with the
democrats and she uses one of the
dumbest slogans in politics which is
country over party
squishes love this line country over
party because it makes them feel really
good about shiving all their supporters
and constituents and fellow
conservatives because they say well no
i've got to put country over party
people join political parties
at least people with integrity join
political parties because they believe
that the political party is best for the
country
they think this political party is
better than the other political party
for the country and that's why they join
that party if you believe that the other
political party is better for the
country then you should join that other
political party unless you aspire to be
a court jester unless you aspire to be a
squish unless you aspire to be a hack
and a sellout in which case you would
join the other party but then on the
important matters side with with your
nominal opponents
country over party
it's so
empty it's so
meaningless
if if liz cheney had integrity she would
just become a democrat officially
but she doesn't so she squishes and now
she says look wow guys here's the proof
that i'm i've got a lot of integrity
hollywood democrats support me okay wow
congratulations
did you like that clip i certainly did
uh thank you so much for helping us to
reach one million youtube subscribers
that's huge now next goal 1 billion
that's right ring the bell subscribe get
the notifications we will see you
at a billion
[Music]
[Music]
you